which just means Frank yeah yeah it's my
frustrating choice to spend all day
cooking in the kitchen now you must
clean oh hello there I am at a sharp
welcome to a special edition of Abby's
kitchen called toilet talk where I'm
answering all your deepest darkest
stinkiest toilet questions our first
questions they come from carrying so
seems to be having some pretty serious
struggles when it comes to the holiday
season Dear Abby I love the holidays but
I can't say I'm looking forward to the
heartburn that I seem to get every
single time I go to a holiday party last
holiday it felt like an elephant sitting
on my chest and I was majorly
uncomfortable I tried throwing back a
bunch of antacids but by then it was too
late do you have any tips tell me get
through the holiday season heartburn
free but still enjoy all my favorite
foods
sincerely heartburn carrion hi Harriet I
can totally relate to your discomfort a
lot of us experience a lot more Harper
than normal during the holiday season
because we tend of eating a lot more
rich foods than what we're used to
plus we just tend to eat and drink a lot
more than normal so this is why they've
actually coined the term holiday
heartburn but don't worry I've got some
really awesome tips here to help you get
through the holidays while enjoying all
of your favorite meals
totally heartburn free tip 1 have a
snack before it's really important that
you try to spread your calories out
throughout the day before a big meal and
I know a lot of people try to skip a
meal or starve themselves all day trying
to save boom and calories for the big
feast but then you're just likely to
overeat later on and get uncomfortable
really fast tip 2 wear comfortable
clothing ditch the tight clothing or any
kind of belt or waist dance that's
pushing against your stomach because
this can actually force a stomach acid
into your esophagus and that doesn't
feel so good yes you may have to
sacrifice style but your body will thank
you later tip 3 use a smaller plate if
you're worried about overeating try
using an appetizer size plate as your
main meal
and rather than just piling it high with
all the foods try just picking a few of
your favorites to start then before you
go back for seconds ask yourself whether
or not you're actually truly hungry or
if you're just bored and trying to avoid
your endless tip for eat slowly give
your body a little bit of time to catch
up eating too fast can shock your body
and that can actually cause a little bit
of heartburn tip 5 choose leaner cuts of
meat fatty foods can definitely trigger
heartburn so you want to avoid really
fatty cuts of meat like prime rib and
take the skin off any chicken or turkey
tip 6 slow down your drinking game yes I
know it's a party but alcohol can
actually relax your lower esophageal
sphincter making it easier for stomach
acid to creep up into your esophagus and
that's ultimately to causes heartburn
so if you're prone to heartburn I
suggest cutting back on the intake and
I've got some great recipes for some
later adult bevies here tip 7 put your
sauces on the side gravies and cream
sauces tend to be really high in fat so
whenever possible serve them on the side
and use them sparingly rather than just
smothering your plate tip 8 wash the
stress I get it dealing with the
holidays and spending all that time with
your family can be stressful
unfortunately stress can actually boost
our stomach acid levels which ultimately
can lead to heartburn so whenever
possible try to find some strategies
that work for you to help you relieve
those stressful feelings I also have a
really great video that you should
definitely check out all about dealing
with those holiday food and body shamers
tip 9 take a walk fight the urge to pass
out in a food coma right after your meal
and grab some friends and family to go
for a nice gentle walk to promote good
digestion
tip 10 save your leftovers don't feel
pressure to finish everything on your
plate trust me your body will thank you
tomorrow when you're enjoying a leftover
turkey
totally heartburn free tip 11 skip the
bet try to avoid laying down right after
your meal because standing up actually
promotes really good digestion so you
want to wait at least three hours after
eating before you lay down to bed I know
it's really challenging but for me this
is a really good time to kind of tidy up
the kitchen or the house but I don't
wake up the next morning to a massive
tip twelve go easy on the sweet yes of
course
it's the holidays so definitely say yes
dessert but try to enjoy it in
moderation I always recommend having
smaller portions all of your absolute
favorite and then promising yourself
you'll pack up any leftovers so you
don't feel like you need to eat it all
in one night and tip 13 speak to your
doctor if you're still struggling with
heartburn there may be some
over-the-counter medications that can
work for you so make sure you have this
conversation with your doctor or
pharmacist well I hope these tips were
helpful for eukaryote for me the
holidays are all about spending time as
friends family and indulging in all of
my favorite foods without feeling guilty
making a few really simple small changes
at the table will hopefully save you a
ton of discomfort so you can party the
night away well guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did you should give it
a thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some of your burning get it heart
burning toilet talk question subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on a happy
[Music]
[Applause]